especially on it I don't know it's like
I hate going down these roads with all
this stuff so I'm trying to remember all
this negative stuff I've blocked out oh
I'm sorry but it was just no it's okay
it's good to purchase I mean it was just
uh yeah I mean I think the basic mindset
they had was
every director and every actor is an
idiot and the movie can only be good if
we save it because everyone in this town
is stupid but us
and that's how they would approach
everything and when you do or maybe
because you made them think that all
their ideas were put to uh were happened
I was just wondering if at the the
weekend it opens at over 30 million that
you have the or or they are well aware
that you can go well this is how that
went down when the movie when when Bob
watched the movie when it was done
I hate every single frame of
this movie that's your call really no
that's like a note I hate you have to
fire your editor he's a he's a
idiot he doesn't know what he's
doing I hate everything this maybe
you're not exaggerating oh no I'm not
exaggerating at all this is what it was
like every single day and then um how do
you go to sleep once it's done oh no who
wants the movie is done and it and he
calls a lot too so your phone's always
like and
um so
at first you try to appease it and
you're like okay they can't appease that
it's just crazy so so we want to fire my
editor who is fantastic and we hired
another editor who I didn't not for I
didn't like him but I didn't need them
so we had this other editor who had been
an Academy Award nominated editor but I
didn't need him so I put him in another
room and he just sort of hung out
doing stuff making coffee hanging around
it's a ridiculous rate he was getting
paid and I continued working with my
editor
and then the morning the the the day the
movie came out Bob calls me at 10 A.M he
goes it doesn't look good this thing's a
disaster it's 10 a.m I would go
are any theaters even open anywhere yet
and then he calls me like a couple hours
later we're adding more screenings this
thing's going through the roof but then
Harvey calls Bob and goes if you had
listened to me we could have done double
so then they start fighting that number
one record-breaking weekend isn't good
enough
because I was talking to some people in
their office they're like oh it's a
nightmare here right now they're
fighting they're screaming at each other
why it's not 60 million
and that's what it was like and then so
anyway
I go to make the sequel which I refuse
to do at first because I just went out
of my contract because I wanted to kill
myself did you have a contract with them
to have a three picture deal with them
which I said I left to do nothing
because I didn't want and then a couple
years later they had fired 12 different
directors for Halloween too so I came
back I go I'll direct it if you let me
out of the third picture
so I don't have to do three pictures I'm
the only guy who negotiates lower
picture deals yeah I go let me out of
the deal and I'll do it so I I go to
shoot that and um
Bob comes to the set he's showing me the
trailer for my Halloween as if I've
never seen he goes every frame of this
movie is genius
now this is the same guy who said every
friend every frame of this movie I
hate so
this is crazy how how do you function
under that kind of pressure I would that
would be too much for me to well it
sounds like it's not even pressure
though it's just annoying it's horrible
because it's not it's you waste most of
you only have so much energy in your
body and you waste most of it dealing
with chaos and very little of it dealing
with trying to make a good movie in the
best case scenario you have a vision did
you write the script yeah okay so you
have a vision you wrote the script and
you obviously they gave you the green
light on the words well that's the funny
thing about them I will say I mean I
don't want to make like everything's
horrible the one the thing that was
really good was
when they go okay let's do it
like they mean let's do it like let's
literally start tomorrow and you're
instantly behind schedule whereas
everyone else that I've dealt with when
they're like okay well they don't swear
like those guys but they're like okay we
want to do this
was that the green light are we doing
this and then six months later is this
happening or two years later like like
the monsters took five years of that
sort of are we doing this are we not
doing this are we doing this I know that
we're doing it again no we're not doing
it
whereas like those guys are like
okay but taking so long
foreign